gotta love yourself a genuine New York
accent the time has come for the first
two-parter of series three of Doctor Who
in this weeks overdue Doctor Who review
so we are up to Daleks in Manhattan and
evolution of the Daleks before we get
too far along this episode does have a
sponsor it is a podcast
it is radio versus the Martians because
it's the podcast it's really easy for
you to get involved in this all you have
to do is listen radio verses of the
Martians calm look them up on your
favorite podcasting listening platform
of a choice doesn't cost you anything
there are no there's no coupon codes
none of that nonsense just really great
listening Kacey Doran and Mike Gillis
cover basically whatever nerdy stuff is
going on in their heads that day they
have guests they talk about everything
from ghostbusters to Star Trek to well
the entire oeuvre of Arnold
Schwarzenegger movies Batman they are
all over the place they're always fun
they're always funny they're sometimes
even insightful and I am very happy to
have them as sponsors for this show
radio versus the Martians comm check
them out my memory of this two-parter
was not good my memory was that this was
painful and having rewatched it um I
think my opinion actually went down
slightly it had been a long time since
I'd seen this in sort of over time
thinking on it as my specific memories
have faded sort of the concepts that
might have worked had kind of bubbled to
the surface and I was sort of lumping
this in as more of oh well there were
some good ideas that didn't quite pull
together and that is still the case but
the degree to which they didn't pull
together I had kind of forgotten this
two-parter is a
mess and there's something especially
painful about a bad two-parter because
of how long you're stuck with it because
this thing fails on multiple levels it
fails on the big scale level and it
fails down to the details I mean I
didn't do that joke about the the
accents facetiously that drove me
absolutely nuts I mean I I tend to get
thrown off by by British people doing
American accents anyways cuz more often
than not it's like I know that's an
American accent but I can also tell
that's not but that's an affected one
but when it when it gets into stuff like
trying to be new you walk oh my god like
and and none of them are good Tallulah
is the the worst by far but none of them
are good the the he's got a really weird
last name so I can't remember right now
but the guy who ends up getting merged
with Dalek SEC his is annoying Andrew
Garfield isn't too annoying because he
they gave him a southern accent so it's
a little bit soft spoken and it's not as
harsh um I had forgotten Andrew Garfield
was in this so that was a little weird
seeing Matt it's like oh they're gonna
be spider in four two movies and then
everyone's gonna try and forget that but
that you did that I'm sorry um but he
actually he he does pretty well but
there's there is a lot here that that
doesn't work even on the big scale so
when I said there's a core concept here
that could have worked the main one that
I'm that I'm latching onto is the whole
idea of the Daleks trying to evolve that
is an ideal with a fair amount of
potential because that's something that
the Daleks just don't do it hasn't
really been touched on I would argue
since destiny of the Daleks way back in
the classic era when which is where the
Daleks first sort of resurrect and bring
back Davros because they they are so set
in their ways they want his less rigid
way of thinking to help them be
better at what they do and the show
hasn't really done all that much with
the idea of them trying to move ahead as
opposed to just being locked into what
they are so there's certainly room to to
have ideas that have stories within that
concept and even even the idea of
merging with humans is not a terrible
way to go about it especially if the
Daleks look at humans and go look they
have this imagination and this ability
to survive and they keep coming back in
ridiculous circumstances that's
something we can tap into that even
makes a certain degree of sense and the
one other element that's at play here
that I do enjoy is is again something
that was around more in the classic era
of Doctor Who that we don't get as much
now which is the scheming Daleks because
back in the day you would get the large
scale like Dalek invasion you know
remembrance of the Daleks Dalek invasion
of Earth etc but you could also get sort
of the sneakier behind-the-scenes
scheming Daleks you know trying to you
know trying to get things lined up to
achieve their goals and a little bit
less of the discharging and and
exterminating everything Daleks and it's
nice to get a little of that back here
but these this this core idea that could
have worked in this one element that I'm
enjoying seeing is not enough to save
this thing so oh man okay I mentioned
Andrew Garfield who does pretty well and
he does he's probably the guest
performer who comes off the best the
rest of them you know Solomon is just
kind of boring I know they're trying for
a whole thing with him where he like
presents himself as a leader and he
tries to be brave but then he's cowardly
and then he is brave again but then he
the dollars just kill him and like it
it's like the one brief moment moment
where he was interesting was in owning
up to his own cowardice to the doctor
but other than that he's incredibly dull
and boring and honestly at a lot of ways
with him trying to like offer an olive
branch to the Daleks we had felt a lot
like retreading that moment with the
two-parter that introduced the Cybermen
where the president
of Britain in that in that parallel
universe you know tried to talk down the
Cybermen right before they killed him it
like it felt like that scene all over
again with the same result so he wasn't
very good the guy who played again I
cannot remember his name it was it was
weird and strange but the guy who was
the the sort of the foreman who's
working for the Daleks he was okay they
did an okay enough job of demonstrating
how his qualities while not an inhuman
guy how certain qualities he had would
be appealing to the Daleks but oh boy
where things go once once the merger
okay but we'll get to that Tallulah
holy cow oh my god and like this it's
not a great performance in general but
the fact that her voice is like nails on
a chalkboard I cannot stand this woman
and like I've talked before about how
much I love the track my angel put the
devil in me I think there's a phenomenal
song but I hate hearing her sing it in
this thing it's not it's not good at all
and you know her boyfriend who is part
Pig guys fine again he's a bit like
Solomon he's a bit dull he's a bit
generic isn't that the problem I think
the big problem here is that generally
for two parters to work you need a
compelling guest cast you need to have a
guest cast that we want to spend more
time with so even in two parters that
aren't the best so like in series 1 the
for the Slovenian two-parter yet Harriet
Jones who it was easy to get invested
and want to spend more time with in the
empty child the doctor dances you had
Nancy who was great and then in series
to impossible planet Satan pit that
whole team that was there they were
really compelling that was that was a
great group for a two-parter and then
the Cybermen two-parter you had you had
Pete who we kind of sort of knew already
so that helped and also like the
resistance team was kind of interesting
here that we've got this guest cast that
we're stuck with for two episodes and
they're just not interesting they're not
compelling they're not pea
I want to spend I'm not even sure I'd
want to spend one episode with them much
less - that is a really key component
for a two-parter that this is badly
missing I need to want more time with
these additional characters and I don't
so that isn't good Martha and the doctor
are okay Tennant really feels like he's
on he's on like a yo-yo or something
he's just like you know no that's not
even the right pause
can it really feels like he's on a
tether or some kind of bungee or
something because he keeps like going
between extremes of you know anger and
her and snapping back into being you
know calmer and more introspective like
on a dime and sometimes I mean he does
that anyway but some of those
transitions work for some reason they're
not working for me as well here and I
think it's just something about dealing
with the dot like I get dealing with the
Daleks bringing out the worst in him but
the speed with which he snaps between
you all need to die and maybe this can
work and Oh what have you done why would
you do that what what do you mean why
would they do that they're Daleks what
he you know the the the severity of his
mood swings in this one feel a lot more
inorganic I suppose is the best way for
me to put it and then and then there's
the Daleks themselves so I like the cult
of Skaro I like the concept of the cult
of Skaro
I like the distinct personalities of the
members within it and then we have the
actual merger of that guy and Dalek SEC
which it it we are stuck with this thing
for more than half the story because he
he comes out at the very end of the
first episode so we're stuck with this
thing for a while it needs to not at the
very least not look awful and just look
at it it and the thing is it's not like
the still image doesn't quite do it
justice because the how mechanical the
movement on these things are it's it's
you know there's nothing organic about
the the movement of these things the
rigid don't things and it just seems so
fake it's the kind of thing that like if
I saw a cosplay convention and it move
like that I thought it was really cool
but to actually be in the show itself no
no no no no no no and the performance
doesn't really work either because he
he doesn't feel like a Dalek anymore and
I know he's not technically speaking
supposed to but there's something about
the the vocalization the deliver and
it's not just cuz it isn't the shouty
thing it's just it's something about
this hesitancy in this I am a Dalek
it's like no no no you're really not I
don't know what you are and I'd like I
understand that though matically that
might be part of the point but like it
just it made the cell even harder beyond
the fact that it looks like it does and
the just the way it progresses from
there that we've got the humans that we
get Daleks being imprinted like for
being a two-parter the tail end of this
thing feels really rushed and maybe
that's part apparently because the first
half feels really drawn-out which is
actually another thing how long it takes
for the doctor to realize that the
Daleks are involved is also kind of a
problem you run into this sometimes not
it's not even unique to Doctor Who but
when the audience knows something that
are that it takes a while for our heroes
to discover it you're kinda you can't
help but check your watch you're waiting
for the heroes to catch up to what you
already know
and there's a little bit of that going
on here because I decide from the fact
that Dalek is literally in the title
even if you exclude that we're
introduced to them and in the episode
pretty early on and then you know the
doctors just kind of bumbling through
the story and he doesn't know they're
there and you're like when's he gonna
find out what's he gonna find out was it
mmm and like and you know that's not a
huge thing but it's just one more thing
there's all these little things going
wrong in addition to the big things like
the pacing like how rushed it is at the
tail end like how just this this idea
doesn't go anywhere really this idea of
the Daleks trying to evolve doesn't go
it becomes this this one story schism
between these four specific Daleks and
then it never really comes up again it
feels like the idea of the doctrine will
evolve should have had a bigger
long-term repercussions on the show and
it just doesn't
so yeah I'll wrap it up there Daleks in
Manhattan evolution of the Daleks I
don't I don't enjoy this this two-parter
at all I think it's easily the weakest
Dalek story that the that knew who did
up to this point I mean I've got to
continue my revisit to see if I feel
it's the weakest Dalek story that knew
whoever did but a certainly in
contention for that so what do you think
about this two-parter whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it whole bunch
of stuff to do
buttons links patreon P o box my Amazon
wishlist is down there because it's
March which means it's my birthday this
month so you want to check it out and
send me something I wouldn't mind and I
promise I'll stop I'll stop
shilling for folks to send me stuff once
we're out of March so that'll wrap up
this one folks so have a have a good
rest year what are you
so all those links down there check them
out or you also don't really have to
because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]